die ja auch es geht hier soll max und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
wir spielen mal wieder minecraft und es
ist kein aprilscherz wirklich nach über
zwei wochen ist es mal wieder soweit
dass ich mein kreft spiele also
buchstäblich ich habe in der
zwischenzeit kaum auch privat minecraft
gespielt aber halt vor allem keine
gaming videos gemacht ich war einerseits
natürlich lange zeit weg also für für
den dreh was ist lange zeit na gut das
waren fünf tage sage ich mal bei van de
nicht blockiert war
aber andererseits hat vor allen dingen
ja das was ich in dem video was auch
super gut ankam wo ich mich so ein
bisschen über youtube ausgekotzt habe
sage ich mal vor allem das hat mich auch
die letzten tage noch weiterhin
beschäftigt und ja auch zum teil davon
abgehalten
das ich videos mache weil ich irgendwie
trotzdem so mir immer noch die frage
gestellt habe so ok nennst du das wenn
du das machst
ich weiß auch bei diesem video jetzt gar
nicht keine ahnung irgendwie ist das
wirklich eine relativ schwere situation
in der man sich zurzeit befindet war gut
das denn wahrscheinlich neuigkeiten die
euch persönlich relativ wenig
interessieren ich habe jetzt ein neues
youtube netzwerk seit heute seit dem
ersten april keinen job und zwar bin ich
bei studios sieben toren
und ich finde die machen halt super gute
sachen und ich hoffe mal dass ich mich
mit ihnen zusammensetzen kann und die
mir da so ein bisschen auch helfen
können
aus dieser krise sage ich mal in der ich
mich da gerade befindet
als kleine erklärung einfach das hat
mich weiterhin noch beschäftigt aus
diesem grund war es in den letzten tagen
zumindest auf youtube ein bisschen ruhig
ruhig um mich ich habe auf twitter und
instagram sowas weiter außergewöhnlich
aktiv eigentlich weil vor allem aber ich
war nie ruhig ja dass nur so als kleine
erklärung
weitere informationen auch kein
aprilscherz heute ist max merker aus
gekommen also merchandise von mir und
konkreter lukas steht für martin blues
also unsere namen keine ahnung das ist
für diejenigen die es nicht kennt weil
schreibe ich ein bisschen schwierig zu
erklären aber ich denke mal dass viele
von euch das sowieso kennen wenn ihr das
mal aus checken wollte punkte link
aktivieren
mal in die beschreibung 1 und jetzt
hoffe ich erst mal dass ich irgendwie
was reißen kann komme ich da irgendwo
hin ob wir mal da oben hin zu werfen
guter wurf gut aber relativ gut gezielt
wo ist hier gut hin
der war doch gerade eben noch hier oder
hat er jetzt selbst in der ferne
geworfen
das wäre halb megakrise ddp sh ich
konzentriere mich jetzt mal kurz darauf
den typen zu klatschen bevor ich hier
irgendwie weiter rede so close up to hit
okay ja das ist einfach so die erklärung
dafür ist hat mich nach wie vor ob sagt
bogan lieber nicht wegnehmen
das hat mich nach wie vor sehr
beschäftigt diese ganze thematik ich
hatte irgendwie aufgrund dessen nie so
wirklich lust videos zu machen da dachte
ich mir das höre ich auch immer von von
euch zuschauern wenn ich irgendwas
schreibe hatte ich nicht so lust ein
video zu machen und dann ist es auch
einfach besser wenn man glaube ich keins
macht aber jetzt habe ich mal wieder
bock auf minecraft habe ich ewig nicht
gespielt vielleicht habe ich auch aus
solchen gründen kein minecraft gespielt
komm schon was ist das wir probieren
auch mal eine runde aus ich habe
irgendwie auch so das gefühl das was ich
hier die ganze zeit rede nicht so krass
zusammenhängt ist und ich irgendwie das
reden verlernt habe aber das wäre schon
ein bisschen komisch in zwei wochen ich
hoffe mal dass man irgendwie versteht
was ich gerade eben erklären wollte ich
hatte das gefühl ich wollte über so
viele sachen reden jetzt habe ich das
irgendwie so kurz gefasst bestimmt habe
ich irgendwas vergessen aber vielleicht
sollten wir uns dieses mal mehr aufs
spiel konzentrieren das muss nicht noch
mal so was passiert wie gerade eben weil
das war schon ganz ganz schön ätzend ich
bin auf jeden fall echt gespannt
also für mich steht fest dass ich mich
irgendwie verändern will
und bevor es manche sagen ja das ist
voll mies dass du dich verändert nämlich
unbedingt ich glaube verändern können
auch gerade in dem fall wenn man
irgendwie ein bisschen unzufrieden
geworden ist mit dem was man macht kann
echt cool sein und gerade deshalb glaube
ich dass
echt coole dinge passieren werden muss
auch wissen ich leide zurzeit geht es
vollkommen oft obliegt aber ich bin
zurzeit in einem freiwilligen in einem
freiwilligen mathe abi vorbereitungskurs
und können mir quasi in meinen ferien
jeden tag fünf stunden mathe könnt ihr
euch das vorstellen
na gut aber was tut man nicht alles
dafür dass man seine mutter wenig
komplett untergeht das sage ich jetzt
einfach mal ich kann nicht garantieren
dass sie nicht trotzdem komplett
untergehen werde weil man ja einfach
mein absoluter todfeind ist aber ich
denke mal das geht vielen von euch auch
so gehen wir auf konfrontation
ich würde fast sagen ja der kollege hat
auch nicht allzu gutes equipment
ich hoffe mal dass das hält einfach ein
bisschen mehr perfekt dann gehen wir
überziehen kollegen und probieren uns
dazu klappe zu zu schnappen
ok kommen wir auf doom komme auf die
nice
das läuft immer noch der ping hat mich
nicht im stich gelassen ich frag mich
übrigens auch ob die leute die früher
immer ping player geschrien haben auf
die es sich heutzutage auch über die 1.9
beschweren denn im komm schon ich hatte
so gutes zeug
ich war voll am nachdenken überreden
irgendwie so letzter versuch
ich probiere noch mal irgendwas zu
reißen das wir auch gaming mäßig ein
bisschen was am start haben nicht nur
vom erzählen
ich probier auf jeden fall irgendwie ja
die tage mich so ein bisschen zu
entwickeln herauszufinden was ich machen
will
das ja und nur so leicht dass man so
direkt was haye das macht es was für
mich fest steht ich will youtube machen
weil ich es übels feiere ich mag was man
für leute kennenlernt ich mag die
interaktion mit den zuschauern und sowas
aber wie gesagt ich muss mich irgendwie
weiter entwickeln für mich stellt fest
was ich machen möchte
aber es steht fest dass ich was anderes
machen möchte und vor allem dass ich
weitermachen möchte ja das ist glaube
ich auch für euch am interessantesten
hier können wir auch liebend gerne in
die kommentare schreiben es ist
überhaupt aufgefallen dass von mir kein
minecraft kam in der letzten tage oder
war es gar nicht so vermisst seit da wo
ich ehrlich weil es würde ich definitiv
interessieren
ich dachte eine wenige flogen co horst
sehr gut das waren die jackie chan laute
die übrigen übrigens die übrigens
obligatorisch sind wenn man gerade den
champs macht käfers habe ich eigentlich
wieder erzeugt aber sind hier gerade in
der mitte glaube dass relativ zuträglich
für unser ziel dass wir eine anständige
runde nochmal spielen wollen aber es war
mega omega ärgerlich dass hier gerade
die beiden ende per geworfen habe also
darf ich mich glaube ich jetzt ja zum
nächsten teams stecken wo auch immer ich
es hin möchte okay das gegner und den
kommerz nun müsse nur wird
vielleicht sollte ich üben bevor ich das
nächste mal aufnehmen
so leute ich glaube das war's an vom
heutigen video
ich werde mir gedanken machen ihr seid
wahrscheinlich die ersten die es
irgendwie entdecken
checkt auf jeden fall maucksch aus link
dazu ist in der beschreibung und dann
war es das
april april also schaut das video ins
new positions